los residentes de la remota comunidad
shuar de río limón en ecuador solían
caminar hasta dos días para llegar al
pueblo más cercano a su comunidad y
tener acceso a internet para reso calle
ese trayecto era su única alternativa
para seguir las clases virtuales por la
pandemia pero el internet gratuito llegó
a su comunidad shuar una antena de 30
metros de altura les permite estar
conectados
ahorita cambia mucho ya que ya no vamos
a poder salir lo que es al pueblo al
acoger señal sino que ya tenemos
internet y aquí vamos poder más tener
posibilidad de investigar sobre las
cosas que nos apetece en el colegio
desde sus casas unas 35 familias se
benefician de internet gratuito
instalado por el gobierno local que les
permite estar conectados con el mundo
exterior sin salir de su comunidad
y de la conexión en las comunidades
rurales a una inmersión visual para
acercarnos a los últimos pueblos
indígenas a través de imágenes vídeos y
música el fotógrafo británico jim y
nelson y en la tele atelier de parís
presenta en los últimos centinela donde
las culturas indígenas cobran vida una
instalación multimedia pionera que
confronta la actual crisis de
desconexión humana estamos sufriendo en
el mundo desarrollado ya no sabemos qué
camino tomar lo que ves aquí es tal vez
su nuevo camino un camino en el que los
indígenas todavía nos llevan la
delantera en esta aventura invita al
visitante a seguir los pasos de los
pueblos indígenas y celebrarlos como
nuestros modelos a seguir
[Música]
una vieja casa en el centro de la
capital mexicana convertida en un centro
cultural
el llamado eucalipto 20 es un nuevo
espacio para promover la diversidad
sexual el arte y la cultura el eje vete
del país sin prejuicios están dando como
visibilidad a un montón de
de cosas que la mejor en otros recintos
no se podrían dar un lugar sin censura
para reflexionar sobre la diversidad
sexual en méxico
[Música]
parece una tienda de comestibles pero
estas cebollas y tomates están hechas
con desechos de bolsas de plástico
este proyecto de tienda museo pretende
concienciar al visitante sobre la
cantidad de plástico que consumimos a
diario
la tienda de bolsas de plástico parece
una tienda de comestibles normal y está
llena de artículos que parecen muy
familiares pero hay tomas humorísticas y
satíricas de los productos cotidianos
que destacan la cantidad de residuos que
estamos usando desde el pasado lunes
todas las bolsas de plástico de un solo
uso están prohibidas en el estado de
nueva york
una revolución en medio de la guerra que
asola a libia desde hace años las niñas
de entre 6 y 18 años podrán bailar y
ejercitarse en la única academia
deportiva femenina de la capital un paso
hacia la igualdad en un país
tradicionalmente conservador
[Música]